IKAI LAN: Sometimes people tell
you not to wear a suit.
And I got into an argument with
one of my coworkers about
whether or not it
was appropriate.
And I don't think
it's ever wrong.
I don't think it will
ever hurt you.
But usually you don't have to.
That's where this came from.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: I thought you
were going to say you dressed
up for this special show.
IKAI LAN: I dressed
up for you.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: All
right, good.
So let me actually continue
with the intro.
This is the inaugural episode
of a new series we're doing
called "Script It!"
with Apps Script.
And the idea is that we will
demonstrate interesting
creative ways you could hook
Apps Script up with other
ecosystems within Google
and outside of Google.
And we actually did a bunch of
this last quarter as well with
BigQuery, Analytics, Twilio,
Salesforce a bunch of
different APIs.
So we're going to call it
"Script It!" and you'll know
that when that tagline comes up,
you'll expect to see the
Apps Script team along with
folks from the other products
that we have.
And the folks that don't know,
Ikai Lan is now on YouTube.
IKAI LAN: I am on YouTube now.
That's why you haven't been
seeing me on these shows.
By the way, Arun was just
talking about some of the
shows we did a couple
months ago.
And I highly recommend the
Twilio and Salesforce shows.
Those are both very
good shows.
And Salesforce, especially if
you're using Salesforce and
Google Apps in your
organization, this is
something that we see a lot.
Because a lot of times you see
organizations they pretty
much, when they go cloud,
they go all cloud.
So it's a really good mix.
And you'll see Arun doing a
bunch of integration between
Salesforce and Google Apps.
So definitely check that
show out if you've
never seen it yet.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
Thanks for the plug.
IKAI LAN: But I'm on
YouTube team now.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah, I
was going to ask you.
So YouTube, people know it as a
great content platform, fun,
informative, just whimsical with
cat videos, sort of the
canonical example of
how to waste time.
So what do developer relations
do with YouTube?
IKAI LAN: So on YouTube, we
don't want people just to
think of us as a destination
site.
We want people to think of
YouTube as a content platform.
So YouTube, we do provide
video hosting.
But we really want the value
of YouTube to be video
discovery and to just find and
learn and explore new things.
We joke about cat videos, but
YouTube is an absolutely
killer resource for when you
want to learn something new.
Like for me, before YouTube, I
would go to a cooking website,
and someone would say, saute.
And I go, I don't know
what that means.
So I have to go look up
what saute means.
After YouTube, I just
kind of copy and--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So
you start your
discovery through YouTube.
IKAI LAN: Absolutely, yeah.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And as a
constant author, are there
things that YouTube offers
that make the
development APIs important?
IKAI LAN: There are.
So we're trying to expose--
we're looking at ways we can
expose functionality from the
YouTube site to developers so
that you could programmatically
manage your,
what we call, channels
and your content.
So for right now, we have the
YouTube Data API, which lets
you upload videos, post
bulletins, just manage things.
And that's really nice.
In addition, we recently
launched the YouTube Analytics
API, which is very cool, because
YouTube has this
function called Analytics that
allows you to go in and see,
who's watching my videos?
Where are they from?
What are their general
age groups?
And we try to infer this date
and let you know, this is when
you added 5,000 subscribers.
This is when you lost
1,000 subscribers.
Maybe you were posting
too many videos.
What's the average minutes
people watch your video?
That's a very useful metric,
because you want to know, are
people watching your
whole video?
Should they be shorter?
Should they be longer?
And in addition, we also have
the Android SDK, which allows
you to do in app videos, whereas
before, you would have
to use a web view
and an iframe.
And now the experience
is much nicer.
And you'll see this on
apps like Buzzfeed--
we did a show with them
a few weeks ago--
Flipboard and a few other pretty
cool Android apps.
So what we do in YouTube
developer relations is we talk
to these companies, anybody that
wants to do cool things
with video.
So this could be mobile apps.
We work a lot with
game companies.
So you play a game, and you
want to show your sweet--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Moves?
On the soccer field.
IKAI LAN: Moves in your game.
Yeah, whatever.
You automatically upload
to YouTube.
So very cool stuff.
So that's what we work on.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Got it.
So I'm actually going to put
just the documentation site.
So what are some of the things
that the developer should be
really looking at?
So on the
developers.google.com/youtube
site, you can see that there's
a bunch of services.
So what are some of the
highlights that folks should
really get excited about?
IKAI LAN: So folks should
be looking at--
the core of everything is
the YouTube Data API.
And we really want to encourage
people use Version 3.0.
It's tagged experimental, but
that's because we're still
trying to bridge some
of the feature gap.
And we're going to
be filling in--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So it's
pretty stable.
Maybe there are some gaps.
IKAI LAN: Right.
There's a couple of things that
you can't quite do yet in
Version 3.0.
We're still going to identify
these things to make sure you
can do everything you could do
in Version 2.0 in Version 3.0.
Version 3.0 uses OAuth 2.0 for
authentication, and it's based
on our new API infrastructure.
So this is the infrastructure
that serves off the API
console where you would go to
register-- say you want to use
BigQuery or the Calendar
API, and you toggle
these things on.
So it uses that infrastructure.
Very cool stuff.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's great.
IKAI LAN: In addition, the other
API here you want to
care about is the YouTube
Analytics API, which uses the
same authentication
infrastructure.
So especially for people that
are doing stuff with Version
2.0 right now, I think it's
really important to move to
Version 3.0, because you use
the same authentication.
And you can essentially
recycle that same
authentication code between
the v3 Data API and the v1
Analytics API.
So don't get too
confused there.
All of our new APIs for YouTube
are going to be using
OAuth 2.0 and JSON.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Cool.
And JSON is great, because Apps
Script-- bringing it back
into Apps Script-- it's
all JavaScript.
And JSON just becomes very
quickly a native object that
we can build and integrate with
various APIs that Apps
Script provides, very quickly
iterate through these objects
and be able to update a
spreadsheet or a calendar or a
lot of interesting things that
we'll hopefully demonstrate
very quickly.
IKAI LAN: Apps Script also
parses XML, right?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: It does.
It does.
XML is a first class item,
but I prefer JSON.
I'm a little lazy when it
comes to parsing things.
And if I can just say, JSON dot
parse and pass it a string
that, to me, wins over building
a lot more complex
parsing algorithms that the
XML services require.
So what we'll do is actually,
we'll dive into and talk
through some of the examples
that we had
cooked up for this session.
The hope is that at the end of
it, you'll see interesting
capabilities where the data
comes from the YouTube Data
API and the Analytics API.
And then you can do something
very cool and useful from the
apps side of things.
So apps means Gmail, calendar,
spreadsheets, and so on.
And there's actually a few
folks that have done some
interesting things with the
YouTube API already.
The first one that I think is
noteworthy is this example
library here by James Ferrara.
You can find this very easily.
Just search for James Ferrara
script examples.
I think this is the label
that he uses.
And you can find it here.
And you can open an
issue with him if
there are any questions.
But what they've done is taken
the v2 API of the YouTube API,
the v2 version, and sort
of wrapped it around
and created a service.
So they can say, YouTube app
dot get standard feed.
YouTube app dot get
user uploads.
I think there's a slight
typo in this example.
It's capital T and uppercase
A, I've noticed.
So just kind of keep that
in mind as you're
looking through it.
But James does share the entire
source code as well.
So you can take a look at it
and get started with it.
But for most of the demos today,
we're going to be using
the v2 version, which I think
is interesting and exciting.
And we're going to get
started with that.
So the first example, Ikai,
that I thought would be
interesting is--
a lot of things that we do with
the Google Developers
videos is very time based.
So on Wednesdays, the APAC
Android team does a video.
On Tuesdays and Fridays, the
Drive team does videos.
So I figured it would be a nice
way to take the data from
those playlists, the video
data, and then
plot it on a calendar.
IKAI LAN: OK.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So we'll get
started with that example.
So the first thing that--
Ikai mentioned this already--
is that you have to create an
API project, because we're
going to be using OAuth 2.0 and
the API tokens from there.
And I've logged into
a sample account.
All the keys that I'll create
will be thrown away.
So you should be
able to use it.
I'll go ahead and
start Create.
We'll call this YouTube
Project.
And I'm going to see that there
is a simple API token.
And we'll get started
with that.
So I'm going to go to my
script.google.com and start
with a blank project.
And what we're going to do is I
have some pre-built samples,
because I think this is
a lot of typing to do.
And I'm going to paste
this in, and I'm
going to copy my code.
Everything will be shared,
of course, as always.
This code will be up on
GitHub shortly after.
I'm going to copy that
API key here.
I'm going to call this calendar
GDL Calendar.
And we'll call this Create
And you can see that what this
does is it uses the v3 version
of the activity stream and then
looks through the channel
that I was able to determine,
the channel ID for the Google
Developers account.
Get, I think for now I'm using
the last 20 items, and then
I'm just filtering based on ones
from yesterday onwards to
keep it a little bit
more succinct.
But then you can batch this
through and do a lot of
interesting things.
The key point here is
line number five,
which is URL fetch.
So URL fetch, if you're not
familiar, is actually one of
the very prominent ways that
you use to integrate Apps
Script with other systems.
So it's actually your friend.
It allows you to do a lot of
interesting things including
OAuth 1.0 baked in.
For OAuth 2.0, you do have to
do a little bit more of the
call back handling.
But that's actually really
straightforward once
you set it all up.
And then you can actually send
posts and do all sorts of
interesting things with
it with a lot of
addons that we provide.
So in this example, I'm
going to get that.
And then this is the
line I was saying.
Line number seven, I now have a
JavaScript object that I can
just do dot notation on and
iterate through all of the
items in an array,
and really very
straightforward to get started.
And you can see that all I'm
doing here is creating a
calendar called the GDL
Calendar, getting the data for
that particular channel, and for
each item, I'm creating an
event in that calendar.
And at the very end, I'm going
to create a link that I can
publish or just have myself up
on a big board somewhere.
And this is a very
simple, one time
function that I've written.
But you can see that you could
write this to run on a trigger
and see if you find new things,
email me and alert me
and all sorts of good things.
I'm going to save
this and run it.
It's going to make
me authorize.
That's always something
that is typical of
an Apps Script app.
You have to give it some
identity and some privileges.
I'll run this.
So this is going to take
a few seconds.
It's going to create a calendar
for you dynamically.
It's going to get the response
back, parse it, and then
iterate through it and create,
I think, at least
20 different items.
And then for now, I
don't have any UI.
If I go to the logger, I have
this URL that, if I pop open a
new window, should give me
something that's quite useful.
So hopefully you guys can
see that on the monitor.
So you can see that there's
"State of the Script" that we
did two weeks ago
and uploaded it.
There's the GDL women-focused
Hangout that we did.
One for Maps and Drive
SDK and so on.
IKAI LAN: And if you included
today, there would have been a
lot of interesting shows.
I know that, for those of your
watching this right now, go to
developers.google.com/live,
there are a
lot of special shows.
There are a lot of special shows
that you should check
out, a lot of very cool
things happening
today that we announced.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Excellent,
yeah.
I actually did filter it out
because it was too many items
to show, I thought.
But this is an interesting
way that you can keep
up with your GDLs.
This doesn't have to be GDLs.
It could be an episode that you
watch on the internet that
you're tracking or a music
video launch or whatever.
IKAI LAN: The only thing that I
will point out is that, one
thing I noticed is that
you did this for
videos in the past.
So you're adding items to the
calendar in the past.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: You could
theoretically schedule for,
have it run every day and check
for events that are
happening on the day of.
And if you have it scheduled
ahead of time, I think you can
actually grab that as well
from the activity stream.
I'm not very familiar with that
API, but you can see all
that documentation actually
really well enumerated here.
This page highlights what is
that that you are requesting
back, and then a whole
bunch of inputs that
you can send in--
max results, published after,
published before.
And you can really window
in on the exact set of
items that you want.
Does that make sense?
IKAI LAN: Makes sense.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So that's kind
of an interesting mash up of
taking the YouTube API, getting
the data back, and
then showing it on a Google
Apps calendar.
So the second example that
we will do is actually a
spreadsheet focused one.
So what we'll do is grab the
data back from a playlist.
And then we'll populate all
the items to the playlist.
And then we'll then maybe
look at the view counts
for it and so on.
So for this, I'll create
a spreadsheet.
We'll call this YouTube
View Count.
I'm going to say, Tools,
Script Editor.
And again, I cheated a little
bit and got the code ready.
YouTube.
This one's actually written
by one of our
colleagues, Eric Koleda.
And I tweaked it a little bit
to make it more appropriate
for the sample.
We do use this internally
to track our own
videos that we put out.
So I'm going to past this in.
Put in the API key again.
Copy this guy.
And one thing that is worth
noting here is that this is
all unauthenticated.
All we're doing is the API key
is getting passed in, but then
there's no user level
identity going on.
IKAI LAN: Right.
So there's something that's
really important I should
point out here.
This is using what we call
simple API access.
And simple API access in the
API lets you do a lot of
things that you wouldn't require
a user to be logged in
on YouTube to do.
So for instance, you would be
able to search YouTube.
And you would be able
to search channels.
You would be able to use what we
call a topics API, which is
the way we integrate
with Freebase.
So you could search
your topics.
And let's say you search
for the word, bird.
When you search on YouTube, how
do you know if I'm looking
for Tweety Bird or Larry Bird?
They're very different.
So when you use a topics API--
there's a sample.
One of our code samples
shows how to do this.
When you search for bird,
one of the things
may be Larry Bird.
And you might say, I want to
look for Larry Bird, not
Tweety Bird.
And we'll return YouTube videos
that are related.
So this is what they talk about
when they say object
graph and smarter search.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Right.
The Knowledge Graph as well.
IKAI LAN: So that's very cool.
And you can do all that without
authenticating as a user.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's
really good.
Yeah.
So in this example,
still, we'll be
grabbing public data still.
But the API key is still
important, because we want to
make sure that there's some
known entity that we can
attribute that usage to.
That way we can meter that and
make sure that the service is
available for everybody.
IKAI LAN: That's one big
difference between v2 and v3
is that in v3, everything
requires an API key, whereas
in v2, you can get away with
not using an API key.
So that's one thing to
look out for when
migrating from v2 to v3.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Good point.
So one of the things I did when
I pasted this in as well
is I imported in a library for
Underscore.js, which is a
great open source project.
IKAI LAN: You too, huh?
I know Eric has been
evangelizing this.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: In fact, I've
actually lifted this straight
from Eric's examples.
So he wrote this great
blog post where he
explained how to use it.
And he, in fact, made it
available for everybody to
just import that in.
So that's the library key that
you can just very quickly pull
that in and be able to do it.
And you can do--
we'll dive into the code a
little bit, but it allows you
to make the code so much
more succinct.
So I ran the code.
So I'll actually manually
run it for now,
this is on open hook.
So now, when I go in here,
there's this new menu item.
Nothing too surprising, that's
been around for a while.
What that's going to ask is--
the first thing it's going to
say is, sync with playlist.
When I click on that, it gives
me the playlist ID.
So I've kind of cheated and
saved a couple of playlist IDs
that I'll use throughout here.
And these are the
Musicians@Google videos that
we post and share to the world,
and also the Gone
Google videos, so businesses
and other enterprises and
institutions going with the
Google Apps ecosystem.
So I'm just going to pick
that one, and I hit OK.
And what that's going to do is
go and look at that playlist,
find out what the items
in that playlist are,
and load them up.
I can sort them whichever way
I want to and save the ID
here, which it will use to go
and look up the view count.
And then it's also linked, so
I can click on it and go see
the actual video
if I wanted to.
And then, when I click on Update
View, it's going to go,
look through those IDs, find the
actual view count for each
of them, and then show
it very quickly.
So you can see that it's
actually kind of a fun way to
bring data in.
And there's a lot of things you
can do with it once it's
in a spreadsheet as in being
able to plot it, being able to
run a lot of historical
analytics,
and things like that.
It's actually pretty cool,
because you can just go into a
new sheet and do this for
the other playlist.
I'll just grab this guy.
And this one should have 30
or so number of videos.
And then you can see that at
the very end, it actually
sorts it as well.
It loads the data in and then
runs a sort function on it.
And I'll go and Update Views.
And that Update Views is sort of
a secondary thing, because
you may just want to Update
Views after the video's
already loaded.
So you can see that it's
actually a nice view to be
able to see what the different
view counts are.
And you can see the one that's
quite popular, which is, I
think, Lady Gaga.
IKAI LAN: Lady Gaga.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And you
can see that one.
I believe that's in
here as well.
IKAI LAN: That was
a very fun one.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yep.
IKAI LAN: I couldn't attend.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: You weren't
actually here for that?
IKAI LAN: No.
I was going to go to-- this
is what back I was in the
California offices.
I was going to go to Mountain
View, but I had an emergency
meeting at a different office.
I went, no!
So I ended up watching
the stream.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Well,
it's on YouTube now.
IKAI LAN: Yeah.
It was livestreamed too.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Oh, perfect.
IKAI LAN: If I remember
correctly.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So you can
watch it to your heart's
content even on your phone.
IKAI LAN: Yeah.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So that's a very
quick and nifty example,
we think, of being able to load
in a playlist or channel
level set of videos into your
spreadsheet and then be able
to look at it and do analytics
around it and
all the other things.
But when you think about it,
this still just gives you the
view count.
That's sort of the only thing.
Which really, when you go into
the UI, you have it right
there as well.
So it's not anything special.
So one of the things Ikai
alluded to was the Analytics
API that YouTube offers
to the content owner.
They get to see a lot more.
Is that right?
IKAI LAN: Absolutely.
It's the same thing as if you're
running a website.
The view count is like
a hit counter.
It is some kind of--
usually, it's a vanity metric.
And it's not terribly useful
for tuning your content.
And that's why we have to
have something like
an Analytics API.
So a while back, YouTube rolled
out this feature called
View Analytics, where you can
go to a video that you own--
and that's the important
distinction here.
You have to own the video.
And you could say, show me
what countries people are
coming from.
Show me how long they're
watching my video.
And show me, historically, for
all time, or for a 30 day
series, what might view count,
how many subscribers I got,
how many likes I got, how many
shares I got, and what were
people sharing through?
So it's a lot of really good
content for people that are
producing videos,
like you and me?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Right.
Yeah.
So we put out these videos, and
we would like to know, how
are people engaging with it?
What are the type of folks
that spend the
most time on it?
What are some of the localities
that we're not
serving well enough, and be able
to tweak our content and
our approach accordingly?
So in order to do that, this
requires authentication.
And like you mentioned before,
it's OAuth 2.0.
So what I'm going to do
is actually create--
and this, I think, will be a
great example that you'll be
able to use with other OAuth 2.0
enabled APIs integrating
with Google Apps Script.
So everything that I'll be
showing here will be hopefully
reusable and applicable
in another API
that you want to connect.
So I'm going to say,
Create this API.
IKAI LAN: And the scope of
OAuth, if you're new to OAuth,
it's a little bit outside of
this video, because it's kind
of a hairy topic at points.
So basically, one way to
describe OAuth is it's
like a valet key.
It's a valet key for
your application.
So a valet key, I realize it's
a very American concept.
If you have a car and someone
parks the car for you, you
don't want them to be able
to open your trunk.
Because I guess Arun,
that's where
you'd store your diamonds.
You'd store all your diamonds
in your car.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: I'm
not that rich.
IKAI LAN: You don't want
the valet to go
and pilfer your diamonds.
So you give him a key that can
access parts of your car.
And he can still drive your
car, but he can't get
into the lock box.
So that's more or less
what OAuth is.
It's not your main key.
It's a separate key
you give out.
The difference being you can
still revoke it at any time.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yep.
So I'm going to go through
this process.
So this is sort of the example
that I just built out of
sample branding.
So you're going to leave these
URLs there for now.
And we'll come back
and tweak it.
I'm going to say, Create ID.
OK.
So that's going to create
us an OAuth client
ID and client secret.
So I'll be deleting this
right after this.
And what I'll do now is go back
into my example and pull
out some of the other
examples.
Let's go down here and grab
all of this stuff.
That's quite a bit of stuff
here, but it'll be pretty easy
to demonstrate.
I didn't really walk down this
set of samples, but you can
see that it's actually really
nicely written, and you should
be able to figure out what it's
doing just by looking
through it.
In the interest of time, we'll
skip through that.
And I'm going to now scroll
through and make sure that the
client ID here is
going to have to
match what I have here.
So I'm going to copy that.
Paste that there.
So the right place to store it
is your ScriptProperties.
But for this demo, since it's a
throwaway example, I'm going
to put that right in the code
and trust that you guys will
do the right thing.
And I'm going to paste
that in here.
OK.
Great.
And then I'm going to actually
add a couple of other menu
items to my menu list.
So I'm going to say, getAuth.
So we'll just say--
go in here.
And we'll say, do OAuth,
which is getAuth.
And then the next one that I'll
add is load analytics.
And you could actually weave
that in in a way better way.
So I'm just kind of cheating
here and using a really simple
method of using a menu item
rather than some sort of a
nice flow that gets
the point across.
Save this.
Run my on open again.
Close this.
Make sure that I have those
menu items there.
I have to refresh this guy.
IKAI LAN: You have to run it
again, because you were just
authenticating.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Gotcha.
IKAI LAN: See, I still remember
my Apps Script.
I remember this.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Well, hopefully
since I reloaded
this, that'll come
through as well.
Give a second.
Tools, Script Editor.
It should be there.
All right.
Well, I'll run it for now.
Maybe I screwed something up.
Run this guy.
And there it is.
OK.
And what I'm going to do first
is publish this as a web app.
So that is the end point that
we will actually call back.
Because that's very
important here.
Anyone and run as the user.
Deploy it.
IKAI LAN: Now, that's very,
very important.
It's got to run as the user.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Right.
And I'm going to go back here
and tell it what the call back
is, because it's going
to restrict to that
known set of things.
IKAI LAN: Right.
And if you don't do this,
you will be an
error that says, 403.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Unknown
redirect URL.
IKAI LAN: Unknown
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's
exactly what it says.
So I'll save this.
And I think we're
good to go now.
So let's go take a look.
Actually, I'm going to have
to copy one other piece of
information, which I
think is important.
And I don't think I copied
it over before.
So I'm going to cheat and just
copy this from here into this
other spreadsheet.
Paste that in.
OK, great.
So I'm going to go here.
And I'll explain that
in a second.
It's going to say DooAuth.
It's going to create a URL.
IKAI LAN: Already have token.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's great.
You know what, let me
clean that up a
little bit real quick.
I forgot that I was
in my testing.
I didn't actually save that.
So you can see that I'm
storing that here.
IKAI LAN: Hey, that's cool.
You still have all the
civic app in here.
So what you're looking at is
project properties, which
shows all of the user
properties.
And use properties are
stored per user but
across all your scripts.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
So what I did here is just
erased my token so that I can
pretend as if I'm coming
in for the first time.
I'm going to click
here to start.
I want to pick the account
that owns the analytics.
And you can see that that's
the icon that I gave it.
And it's going to say
it's going to be
able to view my reports.
OK?
And I trust it.
I'm just going to
hit OK there.
And you can close that up.
Not necessary.
Better air handling would
be nice there.
And in fact, I'll fix it right
now so that when I post it on
the internet, it
won't do that.
Get rid of that guy.
You don't need that.
All right.
Cool.
So what I'll do now--
IKAI LAN: So let's verify that
you've gotten a token.
So let's do that again.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Oh good call.
IKAI LAN: If this has worked
correctly, it'll--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Good call.
There it is.
IKAI LAN: There it is.
OK.
You've got your auth token.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Excellent.
So what I'll do now is say,
YouTube, load analytics.
And what that's going to do is
take these parameters that we
have written out here and
then be able to load
it into a nice report.
IKAI LAN: Let's do this the way
we were doing it earlier
where I can read these
off to you.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yes.
IKAI LAN: So when you do YouTube
Analytics, you have to
understand that there's a
certain combination of things
you have to use-- dimensions,
metrics, and filters.
And there's a whole page
of these when you go
to Available Reports.
And we'll show you how
to use this in a bit.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Right.
So I just pulled it
up on the screen.
So there's dimensions
and metrics.
Think of dimensions as columns
and metrics as rows.
Is that right?
IKAI LAN: Yeah.
That's a pretty good
way to think of it.
And filters, that's kind
of a where clause.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
And let me actually show you how
this looks like with just
the ones I've picked up.
So this is the window for
start and end date.
Then I'm going to say, I want
the viewer percentage broken
out by age group.
So I'm going to say,
go load it.
IKAI LAN: So what we're
showing here is--
what are we showing here?
What is view percentage
by age group?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Something
was not happy there.
IKAI LAN: I'm going to take this
time to say that I was
getting really excited to break
open my laptop, which,
as you guys can see,
is a Chrome Pixel.
Now, this is one amazing
delight.
I love this thing.
But it looks like Arun's got
this completely under control.
So I'm just to put this away.
It's kind of funny, but one of
my favorite features of this--
it's very, very silly--
is that there's a light
bar at the bottom.
And when you close the
tab, it becomes
the four Google colors.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's right.
IKAI LAN: I love that
attention to detail.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: It is a nice
laptop, and I really should
have done my demos off of it
today, but I didn't get a
chance to bring it over.
I know what I did.
I think this needs to be
formatted as plain text.
So what we're doing there--
get my right zoom level here.
And I think the format is--
what was it?
Going back to this guy here, I
believe the format is-- it has
a specific requirement for the
format for begin and end date.
IKAI LAN: There is.
Isn't it year in four digits,
month in two digits, and day
in two digits?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That is
likely my issue here.
So what I did was, in
this example, just
pasted in some text.
And it immediately tried to help
me out and formatted it.
And I'll just go ahead
and tweak this in.
So we have this example here.
Sorry for all the scrolling.
But you can see that down here,
it tells me what format
it wants it.
All right.
So I'll go ahead and fix that.
So we'll say 2013.
Give me everything from the
beginning of the year, and
then 2013 until yesterday.
OK.
I'll go ahead and find my
script, hook that up.
So all my OAuths should
still be applicable.
I'm going to run this,
hook that up,
and say, load analytics.
IKAI LAN: So you don't actually
have to run that again.
So the menu item will always
dynamically call the newest
version that script in there.
This is one thing
I discovered by
accident when I was debugging.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That
must have been it.
IKAI LAN: Yeah.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: But
there it is.
So you can see that very
quickly, some interesting data
got loaded up.
And that's actually useful
for me to know.
So what I can also do then is
say, let's change it to a
different dimension,
of gender.
IKAI LAN: This should
be interesting.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
Load analytics.
And that's going to say, this
is the viewer percentage
across all different--
IKAI LAN: So what is this?
89% male, 10% female.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's
actually as you
would expect it.
But we're doing a lot of work
to make that a lot more
interesting and better with
Google Developers.
IKAI LAN: Yeah, I've seen
the "Women in Tech" show
is a very good show.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And I can
actually add in some
interesting filters.
I can say, country.
Let's just say Italy.
I think I'm missing
an R there.
And now if I say,
load analytics.
IKAI LAN: Now this becomes
really interesting, because
now we can see, are we doing
better or worse with women in
Italy and men in Italy?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And
you can see that.
You can slice and
dice that here.
And all that's just getting--
and we went with a really
simple approach of just adding
it to a spreadsheet.
But you can, as you can imagine,
if you build a nice
UI around this and have these
available as inputs in a nice
UI app or HTML service, you
can do a lot of really
interesting things.
And we talked about this
a little bit before.
One of the benefits of having
this in a spreadsheet is being
able to do this.
The zoom level is not agreeing
with me here.
IKAI LAN: It's also--
ARUN NAGARAJAN: I think
I selected--
IKAI LAN: We want to pick
not all those rows.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
IKAI LAN: And this will create a
chart, which is really nice.
What are we doing here?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: It's not happy
with something here.
Well, we'll just pick this guy,
see if that is happier,
something a little bit
more succinct.
Oh, you know why?
Because the formatting--
it doesn't know what the formats
are, which is OK.
You can see that it should
be able to do a--
IKAI LAN: A pie chart, yeah.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Oh, that's
not what I want to do.
It doesn't like that.
I think it's because I've
changed the type.
But you get the idea.
I should be able to
copy this over.
Let's see if that picks
it up here.
IKAI LAN: And this is one thing
we mentioned on the
Google Analytics show we did a
couple months ago, which is
the nice thing about
building this into
Apps Script is that--
if you type number, you want
to go ahead and change the
type to number.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: I thought when
I copy pasted it, it
should change it.
IKAI LAN: Not always.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: But if not,
let's just say normal.
IKAI LAN: Is that you can grant
access to a wider group
of people for your analytics
that you may not want access
to your YouTube channel.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Right.
IKAI LAN: So if I give you
access to my YouTube channel,
you can do everything.
You can edit videos.
And I might not want that.
I might just want you to be
able to read the data.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Right.
IKAI LAN: So by doing it this
way, you can still get the
analytics, and you can still
make decisions without
necessarily having
write access.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Exactly.
So this data, as you can see, at
no point did I have access
to-- if I have it run as myself
rather than the user
accessing it, at no point would
I have to share the
password for the account or
even decide exactly what
reports they want to see.
Maybe the analytics API is too
robust, and there's just too
many options.
You can filter it down.
And that's a useful thing.
IKAI LAN: And it's useful
too for just general--
YouTube, you can grant what's
called read only scope.
So in OAuth, you have this
concept of scope.
So if I really didn't trust
Arun, I would only give him
read only scope, because then
even when he does have my
developer key, he can't
make changes.
Because all that developer key
is authorized to do are reads
and not writes.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: All right.
I'm going to try this one last
time, and if it doesn't work,
you guys will just
have to trust me.
IKAI LAN: It's the
law of demos.
That's what it is.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah, it doesn't
want to pick it up.
Something is funky about it.
But you get the idea.
IKAI LAN: We'll dig
into this later.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
It should be able to pick up
this data and be able to plot
it in a nice way.
So hopefully there's three
examples that we showed, all
of which we'll have up.
IKAI LAN: So let's expand a
little bit more into what some
of the other dimensions are.
We've shown age and gender,
which are very, very cool.
But a lot of people sometimes
ask us, what's the break down
by country?
We purposely didn't show that
one the show, because right
before the show, we ran the
country report, and it goes
through every country
in the world.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And
it takes a while.
So let's actually wrap on that,
because if it takes
forever, who cares?
So let's see what the right way
to specify that would be.
If I go down to--
IKAI LAN: Again, you
want to go to the
available reports page.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Right.
IKAI LAN: And you'll
see all of these.
You'll see you have
lots of different
dimensions and metrics.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So how
should I do this?
I should do it by month?
IKAI LAN: We could
do it by country.
Will you do it by country
and see views?
We can do comments.
And you can see that we also
get subscribers gained,
subscribers lost.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So let's do
country and comments, yeah?
Dimension of country.
IKAI LAN: We don't get that many
comments, I don't think,
but what the heck.
This'll be fun.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And the
metric is comment.
IKAI LAN: Let's see
where all these
comments are coming from.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: OK.
And then we can say,
load analytics.
And for that, you can see that
these are the abbreviated
standard form.
IKAI LAN: So there's Mexico.
And CA I believe is Canada.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Canada.
Very active.
IKAI LAN: That's the
land of Dan.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Very
active there.
Well, we're actually quite
active as well.
IKAI LAN: US, very active.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: We tend to
leave yes or up or down
comments quite a bit.
And also Great Britain.
IKAI LAN: Great Britain, yeah.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So useful
information.
And you can see how easy--
once the hard work is done about
being able to load the
parameters, you can see that
you can do a lot of
interesting things
pretty quickly.
IKAI LAN: And I'm curious
to see minutes
watched on this metric.
And we probably won't
run that now because
that'll take too long.
But for instance, if you are a
channel owner, one thing that
we would learn from this is,
hey, all of our content is
very English-speaking
-language-centric.
Maybe we should offer captions
with translations.
Or maybe we should think about
offering local content for
some underserved but important
developer populations.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Right.
So we can actually do that,
I believe, pretty quickly.
We have quite a few countries
that people--
IKAI LAN: It's just going
to keep going, man.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: All right.
So we'll do that real
quick, and then I
should be able to do--
what is it?
Minutes watched.
IKAI LAN: Minutes watched.
And you'll notice that now
country is an option as a
filter, which is the third
rightmost column.
So when you go to minutes
watched, we can do, for
instance, the last 30 days,
minutes watched.
Estimate minutes watched, and
you can filter by country.
You see it in the third row?
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Gotcha.
So dimensions is minutes
watched, yeah?
IKAI LAN: Right.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Or
was it metric?
No, metric was minutes
watched.
IKAI LAN: Right.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And the
dimension was nothing.
IKAI LAN: Dimension is-- we'll
pick 30 days or something.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Let's
do 30 day totals.
IKAI LAN: Yeah.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And you can have
this all in a drop down.
It doesn't have to be
this complicated.
And then filter.
IKAI LAN: And the
filter syntax is
a little bit different.
You do the filter name, equals,
equals, and the
country code.
So let's take a look
to see how often--
and it's giving us everything
for the last 30 days.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Yeah.
And this is not really sorted
in any useful way.
But you can see that this is
going to give me the minutes
watched and should roll this up
to dollars, because we're
quite popular, some of
these videos are.
And you should be able to see
what days are the best for
viewership and so on.
IKAI LAN: Right.
And what's really great is that
you can slice and dice
the data and draw useful
information.
Google is a very data
driven company.
I think that we sometimes
go on intuition.
My intuition is that when we do
English language content,
it will be more popular in
English speaking countries.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Right.
IKAI LAN: But then again, we
really want to see where are--
one thing that, again, you could
just draw a correlation.
Maybe there's a place with a
lot of views, but with very
low minutes watched.
And we want to figure
out, why is that?
How can we better tune our video
content to serve those
populations?
So you can do a ton of cool
stuff with YouTube Analytics
if you're running any kind of
video site or video channel.
There's one thing I forgot to
mention, which is that there's
something called the
Partner API.
So let's say that you're using
the Partner API because you
are a content owner.
And what you can do is you can
claim copyright on videos.
And what you'll be able to do is
you'll also be able to run
analytics on those videos,
even if you
didn't upload them.
But you have to claim that I own
the rights to this video.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: That's
really cool.
I didn't know about that.
IKAI LAN: That is really cool.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: So I think that
we're approaching time.
And so hopefully this was a very
useful session of being
able to take the pieces
that are available.
And we didn't build any
infrastructure here, no SDKs.
IKAI LAN: That is something I
forgot to mention, which is
that if you are a channel owner
and a content creator,
you might not have
infrastructure to run reporting.
And with Apps Script
you have--
I don't want to call it
lightweight because it's very
powerful-- you have very
agile, very nimble
infrastructure to go ahead and
build reporting or dashboards
for your content.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Right.
And so at the end of it, you
have a couple examples that
you can walk away with.
We'll put it all on GitHub.
And thank you, Ikai Lan, very
much for being on our first,
inaugural "Script It!"
series video.
IKAI LAN: No problem.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: And hopefully
there'll be
a lot more to come.
And I learned a lot about
the YouTube APIs.
Thank you very much for
all the pointers.
And I hope you enjoyed this.
IKAI LAN: And for those of you
guys that are here from the
YouTube side of things, we are
doing weekly YouTube shows.
So developers.google.com/live,
and you'll
find our YouTube shows.
I think we're doing
one tomorrow.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Excellent.
IKAI LAN: And we're
talking about--
tomorrow's show is going
to be really-- we're
talking about WebM.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Oh, excellent.
That's the new open standard
that Google's behind.
IKAI LAN: Yeah.
It's going to be a deep dive.
It's going to be very technical,
very, very nerdy,
very geeky.
I'm going to be watching it.
I'm going to watch it over and
over until I understand it.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: I'll try
to join in as well.
Well, with that, thank you
very much, and I hope you
enjoyed the show.
IKAI LAN: Thank you guys.
And we'll see you next time.
ARUN NAGARAJAN: Thank you.